[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté aujourd'hui vous avez fait un joli
marché est un marché original et drôle
de chose là est en marche et pas cher
c'est pas vrai mais tout ce qui nous
rapproche toujours de faire des choses
chères et aujourd'hui c'est la portée de
tout le monde toutes les bourses
alors expliquez-moi de plus cela parce
que je suis surprise eh bien on va faire
des oreilles de porc farci des pieds de
porc qu en salade et la tête d'agneau au
four à la persillade
il s'agissait pas du luxe non parce
écoutez vous trouver une oreille et de
porte à 3 francs 3 fera même pas le prix
d'un père si fruit de six francs les
deux mêmes vous savez jumelées can then
beaucoup ils vous laissent pantois
parler d'eux le pire époque ça coûte 6
fera et encore il vous faut rompre ils
peuvent vous a donné deux pareils la
tête c'est pareil si cette phrase et
vous marge est bien pour deux personnes
à lorient dès 3 ans à hama et essayer
prix où ça quand même pas ces états
d'âme
alors ça vous l'achetez où vous l'avez
au jardin mais ça c'est un petit surplus
ce n'est pas grand chose non plus c'est
à dire c'est vous faire le bouillon
avant de leur expliquer moi ne nous en
mêlons pas on a dit ça on a acheté aux
halles ce matin bordeaux trois fronts
seafrance est francs voilà évidemment
vous allez ajouter quelques centimes
parce qu'il ya tout ça mais oui oui
alors ça c'est quoi alors ça c'est pour
faire un nouveau lion a indiqué nous
n'en verrons mais réduire tout ça dans
le brouillard alors avec quoi
là on a un jour au nom du jambon et au
nom de la ventrèche alors la ventrèche
ça te rend presque tout le monde nous
devant de cet avantage
c'est c'est facile à prouver de la
ventrèche c'est cette partie là du
cochon sous la cote
tout ça est alors la relève les côtes il
vous reste ça que vous savez que vous
pouvez que vous voulez n'importe qui
peut se la faire vous demander de la
poitrine fraîche et vous la faites vous
même voie maltée il faut quand même être
faire un peu l'interprète parce que chez
vous olivia ventrèche mais dans d'autres
régions de france car si vrai qu'on nous
le monde est souvent est passé de la
poitrine de porc ou du lard maigre qu'on
utilise ses sous à leur foi l'a pas mal
de lettres qui ne veut ce qui me
reviennent je réponds pas c'est ça j'ai
répondu à tout le monde
ça y est alors là vous avez évidemment
un peu d'armes dans l'armagnac et la de
la belle salade pour faire joli vous
allez voir on va s'en servir mais les
très jolies des pommes de terre et notre
joli petit variétés de salades des
poireaux des tomates
des oeuvres du chou à faire tout d'une
feuille de chou de l'échalote de l'eau
niort dû verser à ivry merci et puis
j'ai oublié ma petite ciboulette que
vous aimez tant et celui là aussi un
persil et les carottes et le chou que je
viens donner le meilleur avec tout ça
comme ça qu'on rate ont commencé eh bien
on va faire le bouillon et on va mettre
à cuire quoi les légumes les oreilles le
pied que si vous allez mettre là d'où
tout à cuire la gemmi de loi bouillir à
lorient et nice et bordeaux
donc on le met à l'eau chaude à l'eau
chaude alors je vais lui celle du gros
du gros iphone lors du gros sel du
poivre
ah c'est comme d'habitude n'a jamais
quand ça fait ça oui je peux en oignon
je mets des poux de girofle et hippiques
et 2 d'art et bien sûr c'est de lancer
suivant l'ag beau joueur m que 4 mars
que le pot il ya pas beaucoup d'eau déjà
pas mal un calcul du raf s'est beaucoup
de salons du bon goût je vais à l'oignon
ça y est la viande
mes deux oreilles je les garde je vais
te détacher parce qu'après j'en ai des
arts nuit tout à l'heure un oui alors
comment des pratiques et commis deux
oreilles de cochon de j'aurais bien
propre bien nettoyer n'a remarqué
voilà je vais pas vous demander comme
bien les nettoyer quand même c'est
propre c'est joli open en battant le
mans pau attendait là voilà voilà c'est
joli c'est pure sellette mais le légume
très bien alors le légume il faut mais
voilà un poireau pour jouer le raccourci
et parce qu'il est trop long voilà il
faut du jour et on y met tous voilà tout
ce qu'ils avaient sur la table va faire
une ça me semble tout ça n'aura ça
s'était mal à garder pour la manger ce
soir peut-être certains là et ça veut
dire combien de temps tout ça les
cédants cuir bien deux heures de temps
bien vos oreilles rats et on couvre
alors ça nous laisse le temps de faire
autre chose maintenant
oui on va préparer quoi on va préparer
la farce pour nos oreilles de cochon
qu'est-ce qu'il faut du jambon de la
ventrèche du plein et tout ce qu'il faut
pour faire notre petit chiffre allant
vite
comment le jambon le jambon c'est un
joli jambon de pays dans la vente de
maillots que vous allez coupe et on sent
bien la tension ne pas vous rendre et le
coupé dans l'estomac ce qui serait quand
même regrettable
les résultats on va sortir la couenne et
que je mettrai dans ma soupe
il suffit il faut pas la gaspiller
puisque ces termes il a passé à la
moulinette et vous vous allez commencer
à mouliner oui voilà ça demain avec le
vieux h par des familles qu est le
meilleur de tous
on tourne ça y est et ça passe on ré la
poitrine de porc fraîche
bon ça y est ma famille alors vous me le
donner cela mais louis légèrement salez
poivrez salez poivrez assaisonner c'est
comme il faut voilà et ça c'est la fumée
s'élever très bien ça les rend si je
tourne et on se voit là je vais mettre
l'ail et l'oignon
voilà de la biologie qui a été hachée
comme ça ce sera mieux pour vous à
gueugnon frayer et puis c'est tout autre
chose
au moins 12 fois ça passe quand même non
l'échalote
on l'a déjà d'ailleurs s'il vous le
passez aussi la moulinette
oui ça n'abîme pas non ça donnera du
bout alors là je vais prendre du père
bon ben je finis vous le tournez vous
tourner un petit peu et pourquoi est ce
que vous allez prendre du passé pour
lier j'ai offert de la place parce que
là je n'avais plus ma femme est là alors
moi regardez ce que je fais toujours
pareil et moi je suis de là vient
couronner la croix merci mon dieu pour
le pain de ce jour de ce genre moi j'ai
toujours vu faire ça et je ferai tout
paris les enfants le font c'est comme ça
longtemps alors je monument de pair avec
la croûte avec la croûte
ah oui alors partir de la mi la veille
de l'eau du lait comme on veut c'est
pareil on peut mettre de l'eau du lait
c'est pareil c'est pareil mais il faut
que ce soit humide là et vous le c
rêviez
ah oui là vous les aurez or les sens je
vous apporte sa non à vous le passez
aussi à la moulinette tout tout tout
tout au tout allons-y du monde
évidemment s'il était c'est qu'il
passerait pas du tout non puis ça serait
ça ça abolirait pas oui d'accord payer
là sa bonté bon c'est bon je crois
allez-y
et qu'est ce que vous avez à faire de
cette farce maintenant je vais la faire
revenir dans de la graisse à nos essais
seulement on a mis de l'huile
ça c'est pour faire une farce qu'est ce
que c'est rare en denrées c'est rarement
pour faire d eux
c'est sophie borgeaud agressé ne s'est
pas de ville denise âge que lui
d'ordinaire pas donner un bout
supplémentaire
non là ça va il faut pas que ça soit
saisie saisissez il alors il faut bien
que l'oignon et l'échalote et tout ça ça
ça viendrait vitaux et parce que c'est
mélangé avec son amant oui ça donne un
parfum extraordinaire et bien sûr et
c'est délicieux et un côté vous n'avez
pas saler poivrer enveloppe parce que le
jambon et ça l'est déjà
et la ventrèche et parfumé et la
pratique casseroles je devine soirée et
toujours pareil
et voilà et moi je flamme moi j'aime les
choses flambée je vous ferai remarquer
quand même que vous vous aviez dit que
vous faisiez aujourd'hui la cuisine bon
marché dans le but un peu leur maniaco
pas tant aimé et c'est un menu qui vous
va vous coûter peut-être ses gains de
francs 50 francs pour trois personnes
ouais alors qu'arrivait auditions les
avocats et des gelées en armagnac
oui on a été voir que ça mijote un
moment ça oui qu'est ce qu'on va faire
qu'un instant on va s'occuper de la tête
d'agneau grillées et persillée 7 francs
pas cher un repas pour une personne
normale oui 2 si l on petit appétit
il y en a et comment est ce qu'on fait
bon alors là je les coupe et j'ai fait
deux groupes est oui alors voilà et là
il ya la langue
voyez là vous avez la cervelle et là
vous avez les joues ils sont excellents
alors je vais salez et poivrez ma tête à
l'extérieur et à l'intérieur intérieur
et à l'intérieur voilà on a dit qu'on a
trouvé maintenant même dans les grandes
surfaces les dordognots comme n'importe
où grâce à ce genre
ah oui c'est le printemps cette année
oui mais on va faire pas mal de trucs
avec sanyo bastien d'été où il ya la
nuit au plus ou moins de bord les uns
que les autres vous allez voir ça et là
notre channel race l'agneau de pauillac
les grands crus et l'agneau de tarbes s
est alors que je n'applique pas tous
milana là alors on va mettre ça je vais
mettre de l'huile ainsi que dolly la
famille le fera chauffer à l'avancé leur
d'azur où il regardera va oui là et on
va la faire cuire 45 minutes très bien
pas très fort et pas si longtemps que le
brûler alors qu'en vingt minutes on a le
temps peut-être de terminer nos oreilles
oh oui elles ont cuit pendant combien de
temps au premier quart d'heure très bon
quart d'heure et la basse est prête
presque je veux y mettre mon heure un
enfant qui colle aux pieds pour liège
était peu pour qu'elle ne se dévoilent
aussi pas oui dans l'oreille et
l'oreille vous parti c'est dodo dehors
comment ça va se passer ça je me demande
ravin à l'entrée moines voilà regardez
comme elle est belle oui elle est bien
leur en prend je vais me refaire
certains comme peu ternes être oui voilà
et on va essayer de la ficeler le but
est assez bon connaître c'était oui
alors la nage en eau vive et où aulas
l'a jamais refermée s'alarmer non non
non non ce serait le mieux ce serait de
coudre quand on a bien le temps file et
loulou n'avons pas le temps alors je
vais fermer avait mes hommes et dames et
vous allez vous aurez là voilà ce qui va
se faire mais avec ceux ci et ça y est
je vous le tien et alors là maintenant
qu'est ce qui se passe on va en mettre
un petit en maille otages là là et on va
fixer des on s'amuse on sort chacun se
distraire à sa phase ordre donc à voir
c'est très joli
je sais pas comment ça sera à manger
envoyez les moi j'en ai marre j'ai moi
j'en ai mangé et c'est délicieux
vous mettez le doigt au fait que sa
glisse mais pas comme l'a été pour un
produit qui vaut 3 francs c'est beaucoup
de travail
récompense à leur bord dont on sait pas
comment dit on essaie toujours
d'améliorer l'ordinaire pour trois
francs qu'est ce que ça coûte du passé
un quart d'heure à de la préparation est
également celui de pâques
lorsqu'il ya des produits qui coûtent
très cher et il faut autant de temps
pour le préparer
alors ça fait une paupiette aux choux
avec une règle et de la femme de rêve et
ça va se recueillir ce monsieur là
encore au four au four et pendant que
l'oreille va cuire à peu près un quart
d'heure 1
oui il nous reste le pm a été alors ce
pied qu'est ce que vous en voilage
l'aider compliqué oui j'ai coupé un
petit nez la chaire lâche uniquement la
faire oui j'ai fait chauffer de l'huile
et pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas
le recul puisqu'il a minor métiers
d'hier il faut que seuls peu chaud parce
que mes passes avec et surtout oui juste
qui dira juste j'ai dit bon et puis
pendant ce temps avant vous aviez
préparé un joli petit mélange de la
londe un petit astre alors de l'analyse
qui rouge là deux chaînes des petites
tomates
oui c'est bien joli mais alors qu'est ce
qui se passe maintenant pour les zones
is a man l'ifn on attendait alors sa 7e
voilà c'est tout pas très compliqué
quand je vais m oui parce que si c'est
sur le mets froids ce moment parce que
c'est dur cc je la t2c un chaud-froid de
pied de porc à la fois mais vous savez
que c'est excellent mais j'en doute pas
et donc pas cher alors là maintenant
faut quand même
assaisonner alors la vraie préparer une
vinaigrette rock un peu d'adressé à
l'autre de l'huile du vinaigre de
l'échalote embêté nouvelle marque
je vis de tout ça regardez moi ça comme
c'est joli comme c'est la loi des
nourrissons oui bon et la ciboulette rit
pas pour rien que vous laisse je vais la
coupe est un petit peu juste un petit
peu dessus parce mais voilà qui se met
très peu là est terminée et voilà c'est
joli et ça sent bon et ola mondiale
reste pour l'instant c'est près aussi
peut-être on va le présenter
tout bêtement aussi les têtes d'agneau
ne me paraissent pas mal maïté selon lui
ces jolies qu'est ce que vous y ajoutez
la un petit peu de persillade
c'est bien ri soliste appellation un
second break moser et l'excellent est
intéressant à goûter là nous avons notre
oreilles de porc bien farcir julien
emmailloté dans la feuille de chou qu'on
a des faibles aux chinois vendeur quand
la rame tranche et ça et ça c'est
l'entrée la salade
elle n'est pas non plus qui est jolie la
salade de pied de cochon voilà c'est
france
garcia les entrées mais lui l'a fait
plus fine pour faire la cuisine comme un
vaisseau pendant famille comme vous
pouvez le faire vous même et on va pas
oublier à soupe et la soupe à la
regarder pour sa part à peu près vous
avez mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
tout le menu complet alors essayé il
faut s'appliquer un peu se donner un peu
de mal faire ce à plusieurs c'est plus
gai alors bon appétit et à bientôt au
revoir merci à des chasses à tout
[Musique]